Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassa
Homage to the Buddha, the Blessed, Noble and Fully Self-Enlightened One.
I asked what sort of things you want to talk about.
I remember two of them, but I can't remember the third.
One was about monastic life, the other one was about daily life, and there was something else, wasn't there?
Not me, not mine.
Ah, yeah, that's a killer that is.
well let me start with the daily life one we'll sort of tackle tomorrow but maybe just say a little this evening but just to answer a question about monastic life when the Buddha left home he entered a tradition of his time which seems to have been had quite a long history maybe goes back even to the
the civilization on the Indus Valley because the Aryans came down from the Russian steppes and either took some of their practices yoga practices nobody knows really but the idea of leaving the ordinary worldly life and to go off and live in the forests and practice these exercises for one reason or another
was well established by the time the Buddha came along.
And it would seem that his age, it was a bit like the hippies of the 70s.
Anybody and everybody was out there.
And when these ascetics turned up at parks, crowds would gather to ask all sorts of questions.
It seemed to have been this sort of entertainment of the age, really, on the full moon, in the bright full moon.
And so he was just joining a tradition.
And the tradition simply said that you lived really close to nature, in that sort of climate.
During the hot season, you might just live under a tree.
And they still do it.
You still find ascetics out there doing that.
And then in the rainy season, you'd build yourself a hut from branches and leaves.
And in the cold season, you'd make sure you get a bit more cloth to cover yourself with.
So it was a very sort of basic lifestyle.
And the idea was that they would go begging for food on alms round.
It wasn't so much that you went and asked people, you would stand in silence, you see.
then hopefully somebody would take pity and the exchange was of course that people thought these were spiritual people whom they could get advice from about their own lives much like psychotherapists these days and so some of them were healers so there was that sort of exchange you see between them and
many of them would teach lay people their practices so the Buddha entered into a particular tradition as opposed to that with the Brahmins the Brahmins were really the priests in the sense that they officiated at these rituals they could be landowners they were advisors to the king some of them very rich
and the Buddha often talks about the true Brahmin, sort of pulling their legs, saying the true Brahmin doesn't do that sort of thing.
He's supposed to be the spiritual leader of society.
And in his district, in his part, the Brahmins really hadn't got to being the top dogs yet.
Over towards what we now know as Calcutta, it was the Brahmins were at the top, and then the kings, and then the rulers.
But where he lived,
the Brahmins hadn't quite ascended to that level and the king still had the greater status in society so of course he belonged to that caste, he belonged to the ruling caste, the Kshatriya caste so when he went out to train he basically took on those traditions and within those times there were
people, mainly men, the women did join them, who would practice these absorption states and some of these mortification things.
So all this he sort of gathered and he reinterpreted it all when he became, after his own enlightenment, his own awakening, he then reinterpreted all this in a slightly different way to make sense to his own understandings.
So he begins, you know, he thinks he's going to, he wants to share this stuff, so he goes out to teach.
And the story is that he meets this monk, he meets this ascetic, his name I've forgotten, on the road there, he's the one, and the ascetic says to him, oh, and he says, you know, you're bright, your face is shining, you know, you're obviously well advanced, who is your teacher, you see?
And the Buddha says,
you know, to the effect, I have no teacher, I'm the fully liberated one, I am fully enlightened.
And the man went, oh yeah, and then walked off.
So I think the Buddha sort of quickly realized that's not the way you get his message across by announcing his status.
He then ends up with his own disciples, his own companions rather.
But as his disciples,
fame grew you might say as he walked around giving his teachings people would ask him to join him and they you know to join him as an ascetic so his his response was apatico come and come and have a try so that's known as the first ordination and after he after so many people have joined him and many of them became fully liberated as well they're established this sangha see community and so then there came this taking of refugees which is known as the second
ordination where you take refuge in him as the teacher the teaching he's giving and the community around him you see and then that became the lay ordination that's what became the lay ordination when lay people wanted to take him as a teacher they would take these refuges and precepts and then they came later on because monks and nuns had all sorts of misdemeanors
So then the ordination became more complicated in the sense that questions were asked.
Certain things like you couldn't be in the service of the king.
You couldn't be a criminal.
You couldn't escape into the order by being a criminal.
You couldn't be ill because what happened was one of the great doctors of the day offered free medical care to his order.
You say, well, of course, people who are sick purposefully join the order to get free treatment.
they made this rule that you couldn't do that so for the first few years we can imagine that they basically went would stay with him to get his teachings and and to practice meditation and stuff and they would go by themselves and just by hearsay not having mobile phones they'd occasionally come across him they'd hear that he was over there he's over here so they go and search him out you see as it grew to a bigger size
there came the establishment of monasteries and mainly for rainy seasons because during the rainy season it was difficult to move around for a start but also there was this feeling that they shouldn't move around in case they accidentally trod on little creatures.
Remember the Jains were also very powerful at that time whose teaching was that whether you
meant it or not if you did harm like you stood around by mistake you still had bad bad karma coming towards you so there was a lot of uh different teachings around karma and the meaning of karma so eventually he had these monasteries here and there and the the population grew and uh it tended to remain fairly close to his teachings which was that
Anybody who joined the monastery had two duties.
The duty to meditate and the duty to study the Dhamma, which meant mainly reciting off by heart his teachings, you see.
We have the product of that in all the scriptures now, which were 500 years, were just kept by word of mouth, you see.
And there's a lovely little bit where the man called Old Age, is it?
I should know this.
He's the monk who... Well, I'll tell the story and I'm sure Mario will remember his name.
He's an Arahant.
He becomes an Arahant and he says to the Buddha, what I'd like to do now is just show people...
where to stay when they come to the monastery.
So it was said that those people who were interested in meditation, he would put in these quarters, because they were meditating.
Those who were interested in the Dharma, the teachings and memorization, he'd put here.
Those people who were interested in the Vinaya, the rule of the monks, he'd put over here.
And the athletic monks, he'd put over there, being the people who messed about.
So people would come to the monastery, especially late at night, when it was dark,
to see this phenomena of light coming out from the end of his finger while he showed them where to go.
So it's a bit like E.T.
if you remember the film.
Anyway, he's quite a character because he also has to give talks to the nuns and the nuns complain that it's always the same talk.
Anyway, when it finally comes to him to pass away, he says to the Buddha, it's time for me to go.
and the Buddha says when somebody says something like that to the Buddha he always says do as you think fit do what you think is right so he rose up into the air burst into a ball of flame and disappeared can you imagine that so you can see there that the monastery had certain sections in it which were devoted to certain practices later on the monasteries entered into cities
And becoming close to lay people meant there had to be a much more intimate reaction with them.
And so there was much more service to do with lay people.
So the monasteries that you see way out in the jungles, well, there's not many jungles left now, but way out in the countryside, they tend to be more specific in their practice.
So they're just meditating or they're mainly meditation.
As you come into the city, the monastery tends to become urban.
So you have monasteries specifically devoted to study, you see.
And then you have small viharas, vihara just means a dwelling place of a monk.
There were so many on that side of India that the state Bihar is a corruption of the word vihara.
So at one point there must have been a lot of them.
And as they came into the city, they had to interact with lay people on a much more sort of...
religious level so there came the establishment of little rituals people coming to take refuge and precepts sprinkling of water all those things that were slightly coming over from old Brahminical traditions like for instance the string that's tied around your wrist have you all you know about that yeah yeah I'll offer you all that at the end that really goes back to the Brahmin string that they hold across their bodies
connecting them to Brahman, the Brahma.
So these days you have much the same pattern.
You have monasteries which are very singular.
If you go, for instance, to, say, some of the monasteries like Mitrigala in, yeah, Mitrigala, or that's in Sri Lanka, or you go to Wat Pananachat or the Ajahn Chah monasteries, they're all very separate huts and the monks just live by themselves and meditate.
And then they turn up for lunch, that's all.
Well, it's breakfast.
It depends on the tradition that they're in.
So, for instance, if you go up to northeast Thailand, you're out with your bowl as soon as the light breaks.
And then when you come back and you have your meal, food's often brought to the monastery.
By eight o'clock, you're finished, and that's it.
You don't eat it again.
And you might think, oh, God, it's terrible.
But in fact, it seems to work.
What's that old adage about breakfast being like a king, lunch like a, what is it?
Like a prince.
Like a prince, that's right.
Like a pauper.
That's right.
And to my surprise, I found it actually worked.
If you eat a load in the morning, and you're not doing much during the day, remember, you're just meditating and walking gently up and down, you've done your exercise, wandering off to get this food, you see, then you find that that suffices.
Other monasteries will give you breakfast and lunch,
and it's the same at Mitrigala I mention Mitrigala because it's a Mahasi monastery these places tend to be exclusively for monks and some will have monks and nuns so they tend to be really for order members but as you move into the city then you get this connection and the Mahasi, the Mahasi Sayadaw was one of those monks of the last century
who brought the monastic life directly into the urban life he was actually invited and one of the interesting things about that was that the Mahasi centre in Rangoon is actually owned by lay people and that's really quite against tradition normally all the buildings and grounds that monks live in are owned by them through a trust or some mechanism but this is actually owned by lay people
and a lot of Mahasi centers are owned like that so here we get a slightly different thing where before that generally speaking the idea was that lay people lived the good life and created good karma so that in their next life they might take on the spiritual life right and the monks and nuns they lived the spiritual life hoping to attain full liberation okay
And this sort of changed during the middle of last century where the meditation techniques were taught directly to lay people with great success through the Mahasis, especially the Mahasis, but also Ubakin and Goenka, people like that.
And the same was beginning to happen in Thailand with Ajahn Chah and people like that.
So the monasteries then became also places of meditation centers for lay people.
So that's what you've got.
You've got, depending on what monastery or what tradition you belong to, you could find yourself in a university.
So Peridimia, for instance, in Sri Lanka, there's a lot of monks there.
Basically, they're academics.
There's a sort of mismatch between the real academic life and meditation.
Because if you do long meditation retreats, you forget.
Because memory is like a muscle.
If you don't keep exercising it, it disappears, you see.
So there was a story of an academic monk who came down to the Mahasi center and was taken by the technique, really liked it.
Went back to his study monastery and began teaching the monks how to do it.
And they were drawn to it.
And then the senior monks thought, no, this is not good.
So they kicked him out and stopped it.
Because sometimes it doesn't work, you see, if you want to really remember stuff.
And then you get these meditation centers now.
So the one I was at, Kanda Bodha, it had a throughput of a thousand people every year.
But it also had a monastic sangha, you see, both nuns and monks.
And we were devoted mainly to, well, entirely to the meditations.
and the teachings around meditation nobody there you would have seen as a scholar or anything like that and then you get all the Viharas in cities which really are there to service lay people so even if now if you go to London there's a Chiswick Vihara which is the sort of biggest Sri Lankan Vihara there's just a continual throughput of lay people coming in either to make offerings
or to seek blessings for an exam, or a pending birth, or anything like that, you see.
So there's that sort of connection, you see.
And the monks there may or may not study, may or may not meditate.
Lay people in the East are very happy for anybody to take the robe and just live the good life.
For them, that's praiseworthy enough, you see.
So that's it.
There's not much else going on.
And those of you who know about Christian monasticism, the ones who we say developed through Benedictine, through St. Benedict rather than, say, St. Francis, will know that there's a routine through the day.
But in his rule, in one of his writings,
He always saw this as training and that eventually the monk or nun would go by themselves, you see, and to seek solitude.
That was the main idea.
Have you seen that Into Great Silence?
Have you seen that lovely... Have you not seen that?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the Carthusians in Switzerland, isn't it?
French Switzerland?
On the border, isn't it?
That's really very inspiring.
Very challenging film.
Oh, right.
He asked for 10 years, 13 years before the monks gave him permission to film.
That's right.
Well, they thought about it for quite some time, that's all.
Well, there ain't anybody in.
So basically that's the monastic life.
And it's not, I remember somebody, I remember this woman asking Venerable Nyarlaponika,
The very man, I think he was a German monk, very revered and very renowned.
He's the one who started the Buddhist, what was it, Buddhist, the Press, what was it called?
I say the Buddhist Publication Society in Kandy.
His book, by the way, Heart of Buddhist Meditation, is still a classic and definitely a good read.
And the woman said to him,
because she she thought of often people think if you're a Buddhist then you must be a monk or a nun like this that's the way they think so she said well what if everybody becomes a monk or a nun you see they said don't worry my dear it won't happen and basically that's it it's a it's a it's a lifestyle and you're either drawn to it or not you know there's nothing uh I mean uh just uh it's not the only uh way to live a spiritual life it's a um
It's an institutional way.
And what makes an institution are the rules and customs.
So a layperson who really puts their mind to developing spiritually wouldn't need such a tight rules and customs to achieve that, but would simply have to guide their lives as best they can within daily life with the feeling that they're moving forward.
and that in a sense brings us to this daily practice a bit so when the jewel of the collection is the Satipaṭṭhāna discourse is known as the jewel of the whole collection and the Buddha is giving instruction on how to establish this mindfulness this awareness this right awareness and
He's been to visit a group of people called the Kurus who lived near modern Delhi.
So he's traveling quite a bit.
He's traveling between sort of Delhi and all the way over to Varanasi and then up towards Nepal.
You know, he's always walking, except in the rainy season, of course, when he stops ill. And he gives them, he's there and he gives his usual talks and stuff like that.
And then he returns to visit them and he finds to his surprise they're actually doing what he said.
And it said that, for instance, there was no well talk, in other words, gossip.
See, around the well you have a bit of a gossip.
So he was taken by this and he actually delivers this sermon, this teaching to them.
And what the discourse is saying to those lay people, if you want to attain liberation as a lay person, without going through all this ascetic business, this is the way to do it.
So in that discourse, it's basically about the meditation practice we're doing and how to overcome these hindrances, everything we've talked about.
But there's also a small section on daily life
which really is just mindfulness, it's just being with what you're doing.
And when you read the scriptures, it's obviously been, what can we say, adjusted by monks and nuns who were memorizing it, because everything is skewed towards the monastic life.
But if he's giving it to lay people, then he must have also talked about cooking and washing and looking after babies and the whole business of how to bring your mindfulness into daily life, you see.
I think the core attitude is service.
service so whatever you're doing you're doing for your own benefit so the Buddha is clear about this you're doing it for your own benefit you're doing it for somebody else's benefit or you're doing it for your benefit and somebody else's and if you if you're clear about that then that this is going to be your attitude
And every time you come to a decision point, and there are many during the day, you just stop for a moment and give yourself the right intention.
So we've been doing it with food.
Well, I hope so.
You've been in front of the food and you've said, this food is to nourish the body, full stop.
The fact that it tastes nice is to be enjoyed, but that's not why I'm eating.
I'm eating purposefully for the benefit of this body.
See?
now it doesn't mean to say that while you're eating greed might not come in and you find yourself shoveling it in but as soon as you do that you might stop you say whoa you put the spoon down okay stop stop and you breathe out and wait for it all to settle and then you re-establish your right relationship to the food you see so you can see if you take that into daily life
One of the small lovely incidences is when the Buddha turns up and there are three monks there, they're called the Anurudas, as a group around the chief monk Anuruda.
And they're three fully liberated monks living together.
And he asked him, he said, how is it you live so peacefully together?
And he says, well, what I say is, what if I put aside what I want to do and do what the others want to do?
now that sort of works best when everybody is saying that if you say it and somebody else isn't saying it then you can be tended to be abused so it has to be used with a certain wisdom but fancy just waking up in the morning and saying well today
I'll put aside what I want to do and do what others want to do.
Not as an absolute, but as just a general attitude.
So that anytime you meet somebody, anytime you go into a situation, even at work, there is that attitude of openness to find out, well, what do they want to do?
You don't have to do what they want to do, but the attitude is that of, what do you want to do?
you see what I mean now normally speaking when you do that and people actually feel your sincerity that you are actually open to what they want to do they're usually open to what you want to do and after some negotiation there's usually a little bit of compromise and you end up all being happy so that sense of openness that sense of service
now again just like in eating you might start off with the right intention and then this other stuff creeps in you find yourself being anxious you find yourself controlling and then as soon as you wake up from that you re-establish your right relationship so if you think of service as a way of relating both to individuals and to people
that sense of openness to them you see and knowing that you don't have to you don't have to do what they say you just open to their like a suggestion see the mindfulness the mindfulness that we're practicing really allows us to make you know to try and maintain this awakeness during the day now when we did that global
awareness where you are aware of what's inside and what's outside you see so that it's not tight it's not tight around something now sometimes you have to be focused like if you're if you're adding up your bills you've definitely got to be focused if there's something specific that you are reading or studying or looking at or involved in then there is that that sense of focus you see
But if you don't watch it, it's like this other stuff creeps in.
And before you know it, it's getting tight, it's getting obsessive and all that sort of stuff.
Now, one of the things that you can do is always set a time.
So you have either a little timer so that it wakes you up every so often, right?
It could be any time, 20 minutes, 40 minutes, one hour.
And that would be a moment where you stop and you say, you know, like, what's going on?
There's a, you can download a mindfulness bell on your computer, which comes from the Tichnaghan people in Washington.
And you can set it to whatever time you want, you see.
So there you are on your, you know, emails and your Facebook and all that.
And so you get ding, you see, and you say, oh, they'll put it away.
That's not what you're supposed to do.
You say, oh, ding, you see, and you stop and you wait for three bells and then you carry on, you see.
So that business of stopping every so often, depending on what you're doing and where you are, is a really skillful thing to do because you catch yourself, you see, catch yourself.
other times when you feel a bit more relaxed when you don't have to focus so much on what you're doing you know try to maintain that global awareness where you're also aware of what's happening in you so in conversation you see often we we we lose contact with ourselves and with and we get drawn into a conversation and
if you keep in contact with yourself about your reactions to what's happening just like in the background often it can stop you saying silly things and getting caught up in in somebody else's problems and stuff like that so and then there comes just a basic routine you know just having a morning practice
The importance of the morning practice is that it sets you in the right mode for the day.
Even if you lose it, at least you've reminded yourself in the morning that you want to maintain this sense of awakenedness.
So what do we mean by that?
We just mean that I'm aware of what I'm doing.
Everything is deliberate.
That I'm aware of the state of my heart.
Whether I'm
in a depressed mood or too excited I'm getting too excited about things and I'm careful but you have to be careful that you are careful with your words speech is so easy to fall foul of you see the Buddha talks about kindly speech you see always kind speech honest speech being honest and
most important to me anyway at a suitable time it's alright being kind and honest but you don't want to choose your moment so these these sort of factors help us to just be a little reticent about you know jumping in with our talk you see it just pulls us back I'll give you one example that often happens to me which I think happens to a lot of people you know somebody might say to you
my garden's in a mess you know have you got any time to come and help me you say yes say yes see and then after you think I don't want to go there what am I doing I'm busy now you're going to pull back so you have to phone up and say I'm not feeling very well suddenly somebody's called me you see and all you had to say was you know I'll tell you a bit later I've just got to I think there's something else on you just give yourself a little break you see
And then when you make that decision, it's coming from a good heart.
And if you don't want to do it, we say, you know, say, I haven't got the time or something, you know, I just don't want to do it.
You have to be careful with friends.
So it's just little things like that, that just to be slightly aware of what, you know, of that, of your, of how, of how we get into conversations.
Now all these things, all these tricks, there are many books on daily life, there are a dozen a penny now.
All these things at first feel slightly false, as though you're forcing yourself, as though it's, what's the word I'm looking for, as though you're pretending.
So for instance, you might start off by saying, well look, before I speak,
I'll always there'll always be a stop right now when you when you're in the mode of listening right and you're actually listening there has to be a moment where you become proactive where you've got to answer our problem is that while you're listening to somebody you're already giving your answer see and that's where the conversation get all jumbled up but if I say to myself I'll get in the habit of first of all listening and
and then you find that when you really listen there's always a gap before you can actually speak because you've got to change mode you've got to become active so when you practice at first it feels false it feels forced you see but that's always true of anything you do when you want to get into a new habit you have to go through this process of it feeling practiced of it feeling forced of it feeling false you see but then once it becomes habitual it becomes spontaneous
It's the same with metta, you see.
At first you practice metta and you might not feel like doing it, so it feels false because we think that goodwill has to be an emotional thing.
So if I'm depressed, for instance, you know, feeling down in the dumps and whatnot, and somebody comes along and is really sort of happy, they just say they've got this job they always wanted.
So I put on this happy face, oh, I'm so happy for you.
And they say, I'm saying, no, I'm not.
I bloody hate you.
Then you think, oh, this is so false.
I'm being so false with you.
But that's because you're identifying with this down mood.
You're not identifying with a party that really does want to rejoice in their goodwill, in their good fortune, you see.
So at first it feels false, you see.
There's a phrase, fake it before you make it.
I'm sure you've come across that, you see.
So you've got to pretend to do it.
And then eventually it just becomes natural, becomes spontaneous, you see.
so all these things that you read about they just take a little bit of effort you see keep reminding yourself you don't worry about forgetting it or not doing it or getting all jumbled up you see and when you get that judging mind come in saying we are useless you'll never do this you see you note that as judging so you don't get involved in it right and you just keep reaffirming your right action
and after a while you find your you know these behaviors begin to change towards the positive you see that gives you more confidence the more confidence you have the more the more ease you feel about yourself see but even even after even after you know
years of training yourself to respond with kindness and all that, don't be surprised if suddenly you fly off the handle and go berserk.
Because those habits are always there.
And sometimes we think that we don't suffer so much from that anymore until somebody presses the button.
And then we know, oh heck, we've got still more work to do, you see.
I remember my teacher said to me that he was very, generally speaking, a very peaceful, very kind man, Dr. Ilze Dammer.
And he would always say to me, well, I'm not tested.
See, when I go to the station and these people make fun of me, you know, and all that sort of stuff, that's when you want to see me.
Then you'll know how peaceful I am.
So it's a case of just gently pushing ourselves, just a gentle push towards what we see as wholesome.
So tomorrow we can, you know, we'll see what questions there are, be slightly more specific.
Now there was, ah yes, not self, my goodness.
yeah that's right well this first of all in the discourse which his first it's known as the second ever discourse that he's given that he gave rather and in it all he says is
he talks about control well first of all you have to understand what they meant by the self in those times or the soul something something which was eternal it had it had to be everlasting it had to be in control and it had to be happy if you're in control if you're in total control of your existence you should be totally happy because you can make yourself totally happy okay
so the first thing he asks is have a look at what you're experiencing and just see what control you have so on the body for instance sure we can wave our arms about and take it here and there but on the essential stuff sickness aging and death there's very little control see you can't grow taller can't grow smaller you can't extend your arms you know it's like it's like you can't do any of these so
When you look at the body, there's very little control as such.
When you go a bit deeper, you find that actually you haven't a clue what's going on there.
I mean, I think it's red corpuscles are now leaking out from the marrow of your bones through the bones into your bloodstream.
Have you ever felt that?
Have you any idea what your liver's doing now?
And even if you knew, could you do anything about it?
See?
So when you actually ask questions about what is it you know and can control about your body, you find it's actually, it's not much, it's just surface stuff.
Then he asks the same about our perceptions.
When you perceive something, he's talking about, you know, the way we see things and hear things.
That's completely dependent on our sense base.
I mean, you know, if
If you're hard of hearing, you're hard of hearing.
You're not going to hear very much.
You're going to find it difficult.
If you lose your sense of smell, your taste tends to disappear.
So a lot of our perceptions are, again, based upon the body and also based upon our culture.
Sometimes we can't see things because we haven't got the culture for it.
One of the things that happened to me when I went to...
Sri Lanka was I heard this barking and for some reason I hadn't associated this noise barking with any animals so and it was way up there up in the trees so I said to somebody what is that is it was the monkeys I said monkeys so and I kept looking at these trees and where the heck are they see and they all and and the Sri Lankans say well there they are see and I'm looking I cannot see them for the life of me and then suddenly I see one monkey in in the trees
And of course, once I've seen one, I see them all.
There's a whole troop up there.
But for the life of me, I couldn't see that first.
So you can see how the way we're trained, the way we perceive things.
For instance, you know, the Eskimos, or I think that's not PC these days, it's Inuits.
The Inuits have something like, I don't know, what is it, 10, 15 languages for snow?
Because they see the various types of snow, whereas for us, snow is snow, eh?
Then there's feelings.
Now, the word Vedana covers both the sensations in our bodies and the sensations caused in our bodies by our emotions, so feelings, feelings, sensations.
And what we discover in meditation, isn't it?
We don't have much control over that either.
You can generate good feelings through the metta, but in a sense they can't be sustained.
they disappear, they arise and pass away so we don't have much control over those either then it comes to our Sankara so these Sankara are our habits now this is where we could have some control through our will but we find that we are creatures of habit and we're dragged along by our habits
And so you find that our control over habits can be quite minimal too.
And then finally there's consciousness.
Now consciousness is dependent on the psychophysical organism.
So if that goes, you've no control over it.
I mean the obvious time is sleep.
So you lose your awareness or should we say your awakeness in sleep.
There's always some
consciousness there's always some awareness because otherwise you wouldn't hear the alarm clock it's sort of woken up by this little tapping on the ear drum so that's his first argument he says well if there is this soul if there is this eternal thing where is it where is it in your experience and he's asking us to look at our experience and see well one of the one of the definitions of a soul is that it's in control of itself
the next thing is he points out this impermanence which is just another way of saying control that you can't control it so he asks you to look at the body and our perceptions and our feelings all these habits and even consciousness itself and see that they're all arising and passing away so they're not eternal so
when he asks us to look like that you see he's not saying therefore that there is nothing that all there is is this psychophysical organism and then there's nothing at all so that would put him in the in the category of materialists or annihilationists of his day so he's not saying that on the other hand he doesn't want to fall into the error of saying well there is a soul or a self
because if he does that then he's pointing to something which has some sort of eternality about it some sort of control etc.
etc.
so he's very careful not to fall into the error of a concept about what a soul is and he's very careful not to go into a complete denial of it
so therefore he then tries to point to something which is there which sounds very much like a soul and he says for instance there is that which is not born it doesn't die it's not conditioned it's not created okay so that sounds a bit like a soul doesn't it right
and then he says there is a sphere there's another way of saying it there is a sphere so a sphere as he uses it we're translating the word āyatana a sphere is a type of experience which can't be mixed with another so there are six spheres of experience that's the way you put it so one sphere is sight the next sphere is hearing
smelling, tasting, touching and the inner mind all these are called spheres in other words you can't see through your nose you can try but you can't do it so these spheres are quite separate so then he says that there is a sphere where there's just no phenomena there's no moon, there's no sun there's no coming, there's no going there's no here, no there but there is this sphere of experience
And then finally there's a lovely little discourse, a lovely little phrase, which happens twice in the scriptures.
And the one I'm thinking of, it begins with somebody asking him, where do the four great elements come to an end?
In other words, disappear, annihilate.
Now the four great elements are earth, fire, water, and air.
And they stand for certain properties.
so the earth is pressure, weight, fire, heat and lack of it of course water is cohesion, elasticity and lack of it, stiffness and the air is movement or lack of it and what they're describing is not physics they're not the way that a physicist would describe what there is in the universe
what they're describing is how we experience matter so when you go into your body or when you touch something you'll see it has one of those qualities all the four qualities will be there but some of them will be preponderant
The question is, where does all that come to an end?
In other words, is there an end to all that?
In other words, he's asking about annihilation.
And he says that's the wrong question.
He said the question ought to be, where do these four elements not find a footing?
So where is it that you don't find the world, the phenomenal world?
and he says there is a consciousness and I'll come back to this word consciousness in a minute there is a consciousness which is not touched by any of the senses which is without boundary so you have to have phenomena to create boundary and in all directions full of light and just this is the end of suffering so he's obviously talking about something within us which is not phenomenal
It doesn't belong to this world of phenomena and it cannot be described as a self.
It cannot be described as a self because when you are that consciousness you don't know it.
It cannot be an object to itself.
And you'll find this in Mahayana scriptures where they say things like the eye cannot see itself.
It can't, can it?
The tongue can't taste itself.
Can you imagine if the tongue had a basic taste of curry?
It would be a killer, wouldn't it?
I mean, it's all right if you're eating curry, but I mean, what about ice cream?
So it's the very fact that senses are empty.
They are empty themselves of what they receive.
So this awareness that we are exercising
this satipanya, this intuitive intelligence which we're drawing out of it's confusion with the body confusion with confusion meaning together confusion with emotions so when we I am see every time you say I am you've got to say who see who's see you say I am angry who's angry see with thought especially yeah
Very quickly we are the thinker.
So we're drawing this quality, this intuitive awareness out from that to become the observer.
So when you're the observer, the Buddha says, you're in the presence of Nibbana.
You're actually in the presence of the ultimate state.
But we can't see it, you see.
It's right in front of us and we can't see it.
And what we actually feel ourselves is to be the observer, correct?
To be the feeler.
Yeah?
You should all be nodding vigorously.
See?
And the double bind is, you see, how do you get out of that?
Because every time you want to get rid of that sense of self, another self appears to get rid of it.
So you're in an eternal double bind going all the way back
so the Buddha's instructions are to keep averting away from that sense of self that's the delusion, that's the first object we make averting yourself to actually what it is you're experiencing because that's only a concept in the mind it also has a mirror image in the heart as a sense of presence
so often that's described by people as their soul but actually it still belongs to the world of phenomena because it's a feeling and if you have a self-image like the observer that must also still belong to the world of phenomena to the world of feeling, perception etc.
so it's by bypassing that keeping our attention on what it is we're experiencing as arising and passing away see not me not mine that there comes the experience of who we really are now the Buddha referred to himself as the Tathagata which means the one who's transcended so there is within us this Buddha nature this intuitive awareness you'll find it referred to in various ways
and really to experience that in itself is our aim because once that's known the path leading to the end of suffering is open wide that's what it says but once you know that then it's you can't know it no well it's now that's the interesting thing isn't it because in your meditation this intuitive awareness we're exercising
and we're looking at these specific qualities of impermanence, of the role of desire, and of that seeing of not know, not me, not mine, you see, something distant.
When it sees something, the insight, the actual insight is immediate.
There's no thought involved.
You either see it or you don't see it.
But then it has to tell itself what it's just seeing.
And that's where the mind comes in.
The mind has to be used, the intellect is used to refer back to itself what is just observed.
That's why often some of you will have experienced it, but often in meditation a line will come up, just out of the blue, some insight.
There's one beautiful one by a teacher called Ajahn Mahabua who died recently.
and it's the if you get hold of his book called the heart straight from the heart these are really beautiful talks although you have to get into the into his way of speaking and there's he's meditating meditating and there just comes this line just out of the blue you see wherever if I can remember it rightly
Wherever there arises a sense of a self, that is the beginning of another level of existence, of another level of becoming.
Now, what he's saying there is, as soon as the I appears, there's a process happens.
And if that I, because of the I, of the delusion of I, there's always going to be some dissatisfaction involved.
because this I is always seeking real happiness in the sensual world and it won't deliver and with that insight he seems as though he really moved now that came from this intuitive intelligence telling itself what it's just seeing it happens to us in ordinary daily life when suddenly you say something amazingly wise
And you wonder where it came from.
Has it happened?
Yes.
No.
You suddenly find yourself giving advice to somebody and you wonder how the heck you came across that.
So it's one of the more tricky teachings, mainly made tricky because of the books written on it.
Everybody, any academic worth his salt writes about not-self.
And he just confuses it.
Because it's not actually a philosophy, it's a methodology to make us discover what's real, that's all.
And when it came to questions about the soul, you see, there's a lovely one where this man Vajagota comes up, and he's completely confused, and he goes to Buddha and he says, now come on, is there a soul or isn't there, you see?
He's obviously had discussions with this and that.
He's had discussions with the Buddha and he's finally fed up.
He says, look, come on, I want to know, is there a soul?
And the Buddha's silent, you see.
So he goes away then, you see.
And Ananda, who's with the Buddha, says, why didn't you ask him?
He says, well, if I'd have said there is not a soul, he would have gone around thinking that I would have been put into the camp of the annihilationists.
If I said there was a soul, I'd have been put in the camp of the eternalists, right?
But I didn't tell him that because if I'd have said to him there was no soul, he would have gone away confused, saying to himself, once I had a soul and now I don't have one.
So with all these questions, he kept silent.
One of the regular questions was known as the quadrilemma.
So we have a dilemma, they had a quadrilemma.
And the quadrilateral was put as, did the Tathagat upon death, did he continue to exist?
Did he annihilate?
Did he both exist and annihilate?
Or did he neither exist nor annihilate?
I mean, you can't get around that one, you see.
And of course, he kept silent, you see.
He wouldn't go into metaphysics.
Because as soon as you get into metaphysics, well, it
you get into all sorts of mess.
So, I don't know whether that's been as clear the problem or is made even more confused.
So I can only hope my words have been of some assistance.
May you by your practice deliver yourself from all these confusions and arrive at that wonderful place of Nibbāna sooner rather than later.
Sadhu.